sich einmal fühlen wie ein astronaut im
weltall im zero gravity klappt wird
dieser traum für 50 prominente gäste war
bei einer party an bord eines flugzeugs
[Musik]
flughafen frankfurt am main musiker
social media stars künstler und sportler
aus aller welt schicken ein für das
abenteuer schwerelosigkeit darunter dj
franky tunes aus russland djs oder aus
südkorea der französische fußball-profi
sebastian und der deutsche fernseh koch
tim mälzer
einverständniserklärung für
körperverletzung für das feiern im
schwebezustand haben sie sich besondere
aktionen vorgenommen
teenager möchte etwas zubereiten
diversen vorschläge wir haben uns jetzt
erstmal reduziert auf eine einfache
salatdressing wir haben einige ideen ihr
werdet schon sehen was wir vorbereitet
haben es wird etwas einfach sein das
spaß macht auf geht's zum airbus a310
mit dem normalerweise astronauten für
die schwerelosigkeit trainieren
die prominenten brauchen zwar keinen
raumanzug aber eine gehörige portion
unerschrockenheit 15 parabelflüge werden
sie erleben und dabei jeweils 22
sekunden lang schwerelos sein
in 8500 metern höhe wird es spannend
erst werden die passagiere mit doppelter
schwerkraft zu boden gedrückt dann heben
sie plötzlich ab
[Musik]
kurz danach beginnt alles von vorne das
flugzeug bewegt sich dabei fast wie eine
achterbahn
[Musik]
für das projekt haben sich die
veranstalter mit erfahrenen astronauten
zusammengetan
das mikrofon ist in schwerelosigkeit
während ich es von der einen hand zur
anderen werfe wenn ich hoch springe und
meine füße in der luft sind dann schwebt
es über meine hand das machen wir auch
mit dem flugzeug
tim mälzer hat nach kurzer zeit den dreh
raus und schüttelt sein salatdressing
sebastian r schießt das erste tor in
schwerelosigkeit
die organisatoren des events haben sich
auf ausgefallene partie rein
spezialisiert mit dem zero gravity
klappt sorgen sie für aufmerksamkeit
zum zweiten mal feiern sie die party im
schwebezustand und der dauert insgesamt
rund sechs minuten
[Musik]
zurück am boden sind die teilnehmer des
flugs noch voller adrenalin
ich habe mich gefühlt wie superman und
dann ist kann auch tun und mit anderen
leuten zusammenstoßen
wie frei sein erwachsene leute haben wir
sagen toll toll toll toll toll toll toll
toll toll toll toll toll toll toll toll
toll toll empfangen einige feuchte augen
dabei zu werden es jetzt wohl um ehrlich
zu sein es ist einfach nur beeindruckend
unbeschreiblich toll ich bin sprachlos
das gefühl der schwerelosigkeit hat alle
schwer beeindruckt
[Musik]